You know what, if you picked all of them you're right on. We've heard the term
virtualization in the context of virtual memory systems. Data centers today
catering to cloud computing use virtualization
technology. Java virtual machine. Virtual Box is
something that you may be using in your laptop for instance. An IBM VM/370,
was the mother of all virtualization in some
sense, because way back in the 60s and
the 70s, they pioneered this concept of virtualization.
Google Glass, of course many of you may
have heard the hype behind it, as well
as the opportunities for marketing that this provides.
Cloud computing, Dalvik Virtual Machine in the context
of Android, VMware Workstation as an alternative to
Virtual Box, and of course the movie, Inception,
has a lot of virtualization themes in it.